Jeremiah is with us in Pensacola hi
Jeremiah how are you better than I
deserve what's up I actually just have a
question kind of just looking for some
advice me and my wife are soon to be
expecting a child and graduation uh-oh
thank you I appreciate that but um we
are also fifty-five thousand dollars in
debt and my wife and I have different
ideas on how to take care of that I
agree with her that we need to get rid
of I have a brand-new motorcycle that
was the dumbest thing I ever did but I
need to get rid of that we both agree on
that but she doesn't necessarily think
we need to cut up the any of her credit
cards even because she thinks that we
can pay them and we can we haven't have
enough money to do it but I don't know
how to convince her otherwise well the
question is what makes people wealthy
what money habits
what money processes causes people to
win with money and that's the question
that's the question the two of you
should ask each other okay and here's
what the data tells us that you're
number one wealth building tool is your
income okay and when you have your
income due to not having any debt
payments you have more ability to build
wealth than the person standing next to
you that has debt payments no duh right
if you had no payments you could you
could invest duh right yeah okay
and then you ask yourself okay what do
rich people do well rich people get rich
by not having any payments and the vast
majority of them don't use credit cards
credit cards are that's what the middle
class does yeah but rich people go I'm
not gonna fool around with these snakes
they bite and so if you pay your credit
card off every single month you can use
a debit card because it's the exact same
thing then isn't
yes well if you're not gonna pay it off
every month now you're being a
middle-class person if you want to be
middle-class I'm not gonna be mad at you
I'll be your friend but this is a show
about winning with money and so it which
means build wealth and if you're gonna
build wealth you have to do what rich
people do if you do rich people's stuff
you get to be rich people and so you
know cut up your stupid credit cards get
a debit card if you're paying it off
every month anyway it's the same thing
cuz you're using the same yeah right
yeah exactly
when debit card will do everything the
credit card will do it has the exact
same fraud protection the exact same
fraud protection and I you know my wife
and I spent three weeks in Europe this
summer debit card did it just fine and
so you know and I have many many many
friends that are worth tens of millions
of dollars and they walk around debit
cards in their pockets they don't carry
credit yes and they don't think credit
cards are an essential way to handle
money or an essential way to build
wealth and so you know you just got to
look at it and start asking yourself
what are the methods what are the
processes I mean it's like saying if you
want to be skinny eat and exercise like
skinny people do right he won't be 500
pounds didn't talk to that guy he can
tell you how to do that mm-hmm you know
and just lots of donuts I guess or
whatever you know I mean but you've just
gotta you know you have to decide what
behaviors habits character traits give
me the results I want and then what
tools give me the results on one and
credit card is not the tool getting out
of debt and staying out of debt does
that now with a baby on the way I
wouldn't pay a neck bunch extra on the
debt I'd sell the motorcycle I'd cut up
the credit cards and give me a debit
card I get on a budget I'd pile up as
much cash as I could pile up until baby
comes when baby comes and mama comes
home from the hospital and baby comes
home for the hospital and everybody's
safe and happy and healthy then we'll
use a bunch of that savings to start our
debt snowball and start paying off our
debts listing them smallest to largest
paying minimum payment
on everything but the little one
Jeremiah hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover you and your wife read that
because you have a baby on the way you
need to change your family tree you need
to do what it takes to change your
family tree hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]